do&co nein nein nein nein nein
ja ja ja man
servus leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer runde remote management und mit
dabei sind wieder ein paar leute so wie
immer weil ich einfach praktischer wo
worüber dir hinterher bin mir bewusst
dass die personen die mit mir aufnimmt
es ist kein break ist es alles baker den
arm nämlich geschafft nie dran allein ja
niemand schreibt einfach gegen das gab
trainer in den kommentaren in den tschad
obwohl den überhaupt nicht gespielt
ja ja ja bisher kaum gespielt so als wir
haben ein bisschen gezockt aber nicht
der fahrer und drei weitere sitze diesem
aber ich weiß dass nicht eines bildes
gelassen bei der ag schön im jump alter
schön kaputt gesagt ewig gespielt rage j
die ist so viele damit sozusagen groß
geworden auf youtube kanal media wissen
wir denken mit picchu travel mein bier
geworden ist nichts mit duco nein nein
nein nein
ja denn von hinten angeschlichen
eigentlich alterswehr hat sich der
gladbecker babbel
mich hat immer gesagt aber auf dich
geschossen
im bistum holen so was wie jetzt
neuerdings aus weil du kleiner hunde es
war etwas gebremst hat uns beide gilt
als wahrscheinlich
denn irgendwie spiel auf platz eins ist
die kommentare was ich auch sagen ich
glaube hallo pizza
ich lebe achter da sieht man ja
skateboard die ersten ersten drei
insassen so einem menschen kaum noch
raus ohne menschen nicht so alter kann
man ja ich nicke of rage mod
also keine [ __ ] du bist ein fixer
immer von hilfsmitteln vielleicht gerade
in dem moment als du bist du bist echt
ein richtiger fix wie er im buche steht
ja alles klar bei dir ist dann
gegenseitig abgeschossen zu erklären
jung ich habe gott den größten testen
skill aller zeiten gemacht aber das
nicht aufgenommen ob gott ich habe das
richtig gehirn graf kathrin fries gehabt
900 games rp die hunde so nackig 100
game sondern kulisse sohn
ja krankhafter platz eins wie auch sonst
sehr baba einfach fick dich doch mal
fragen lässt abgeschmiert ja ich bin
richtig
ohne witz ich habe in dem moment auch
jemandem gelingt aber nur 20 abgezogen
und bin immer noch der barbar auf platz
besser ist es heftige eskalation wird
ich habe paul potts gekillt und trotzdem
noch immer kann post nicht gegen hacker
und schreibt auch alle escape nur das in
die kommentare bitte macht ist schreibt
krank krankhaftes und es geht es in die
kommentare und jungen hast du das
gesehen tragen mein gott habe ich nicht
getroffen
mein gott die schlecht mein gott ich
gestärkt jetzt bettelt er später der
monster ja und es gewinnt alter escape
the battle den hund gehört auf platz 14
zu einer punkten vorsprung
ich hab mir grad zu erklären
dort trifft er mich ich bin grad halt
mit einer handsonde müsst ihr wissen ja
ich will auf meine hand
ich fühle mit einem finger sind dicker
was ich hasse das wenn wir diese schere
so verbuggt es weißt du wenn du ein
50.000 trips die schere debug das stimmt
und da ist die stimme genommen ein
hacker in dem
wirklich auch dessen leute zwischen
hecken gehen was ich richtig was so wie
es einfach nicht probiert die hundezone
alt deshalb dazu gebracht
leute schreiben leute schreibt bitte in
die kommentare krankhaftes einmal würde
ich gerne noch demütigen dem kreistag an
die doppelten und kalt ich habe keine
negative gibt es zu okay gut wir schauen
mal wie lange schaut in sieben minuten
eigentlich wenn wir zwar unsere anhänger
wird es wieder besser sagen aber das
stimmt ja du kannst du ein bisschen
erzählen was man ab heute wird ich bin
so ein krasses opfer aber wisst ihr wer
noch ein krasses opfer ist wie diabetes
opfer des opfers
213 bei germanys next ruhen sollen
gewonnen das gilt auch in die kommentare
schreiben
willst du nicht der bruder von klar gmbh
muss überlegen schlagheck gnh und
krankhafter in die kommentare wenn ihr
bisher angeschaut hab ich gebe jeden von
euch der gnh krankhafter die kommentare
schon persönlich einen gutenachtkuss
heute abend und in diesem sinne wünsche
ich euch noch einen schönen tag leute
ich hoffe es wieder ausgefallen wenn es
gefallen hat einen like daumen nach oben
ist beschied falls ihr nämlich feiert
war ich so eine geile sau bin dann
lassen wir von agoda und zweckel leute